ich wünsche mir ja nicht hoffe dass die
menschen erstens nur das allernötigste
besorgen was sie wirklich brauchen an
lebensmitteln und dass wir ansonsten
versuchen so schnell wie möglich die
beschlüsse umzusetzen denn es geht um
die gesundheit von ganz vielen und es
geht auch natürlich um unseren wohlstand
und je schneller wir die infektionen
unter kontrolle bekommen desto besser
ist es für alle eine hand von ihnen zu
hause zu bleiben jetzt in den nächsten
zwei tagen ja ich das ist ein appell für
alle besorgungen die nicht unbedingt
stattfinden müssen auf die zu verzichten
dass man lebensmittel braucht das man
getränke braucht das kann jeder
verstehen güter des täglichen bedarfs
aber es gibt auch die möglichkeit das
ein oder andere shopping abenteuer nach
weihnachten zu machen wenn irgendwann
die geschäfte wieder geöffnet werden
wann das sein wird kann ihnen niemand
verantwortlich voraussagen
denn es gibt einen klaren maßstab und
das ist die entwicklung der infektionen
und der todesfälle
solange sie so hoch sind und jede woche
weiter zunehmen 10 15 prozent
steigerungen so lange ist unser
gesundheitssystem bedroht und sagt
unsere krankenhäuser unsere notaufnahmen
und solange ist die gesundheit von 80
millionen deutschen bedroht